okay can you keep it down
I have suck on the phone here at Wired
we can't get enough Star Wars and
nothing is more iconic in the Star Wars
universe than the lightsaber lots of
manufacturers have made lightsabers but
generally these have been low quality
toys for kids or high-quality prop
replicas that just slipped on shelves
people were hungry for more from their
lightsabers a DIY community of saber
Smith's like Vader's vault Ultra sabers
and saber Forge are finally beginning to
meet these needs so what makes each
lightsaber special here's the new saber
that you've been seeing everywhere
it's Hasbro's kylo Ren model the new
three bladed darkside red splitter from
the force awakens realistic sounds check
fancy new cross guard check inexplicable
cable running down the side yep
for a few hundred you can unsheath the
slim combat-ready lightsaber called the
ardent Ely built by Vader's well the
grip is much slimmer on graders vault
savers because these things are actually
made for fighting not feeling that loose
blue try a photon blade or yoda green
this is the ultra sabers Graflex it's a
replica of the saber obi-wan gave Luke
and a new hope like the Raiders vault
models it features switchable sounds and
replaceable blades it also has a flash
on clash effect which you've got to have
if you're trying to work something out
with dear old dad for the truly bespoke
Jedi turn to Acme sabers which only
makes a few custom models a year but
these things are truly custom this one
has an activation box with a kill switch
power button and sound button which can
toggle through sound and class settings
want that rugged built from junkie
scammed off a Java look get a star fall
saber these are constructed from found
pieces of metal the company makes
different tiers of sabers from the super
fancy with changing blade colors
changeable sounds and clashing features
to Dueling models star wars season is in
full effect which means you've still got
time to find a lightsaber that's built
for you
you